good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this special press conference
after special meeting of the European
Council without further ado I invite the
President of the European Council to
take the floor let me first of all thank
you for your patience I know that it has
taken the from garden plant but we are
still on time we have agreed the whole
package before the first session of the
European Parliament five years ago we
needed three months to the site and
still some readers were against this
year it was three days and nobody was
against even if Germany abstained on the
Commission president
due to some issues in the government
coalition personally Chancellor Merkel
supported the whole package first and
foremost we have chosen two women and
two men for the four key positions a
perfect gentleman I am really happy
about it after all you're a busy woman I
think it was worth waiting for such an
outcome we have proposed or sulla von
der Leyen as the next president of the
European Commission and nominated
Christine Lagarde of the candidate for
president of the European Central Bank
we have selected Sharma shell of the
next president of the European Council
and president of the euro summit as well
as nominated Joseph Burrell as the
candidate for high representative of the
Union for Foreign Affairs and security
policy
it will now be for the European
Parliament to consider Russell upon the
lion for the Commission president if
elected she will be the first woman to
lead the European Commission char Michel
will with his experiences
Prime Minister the idea of finding
consensus and building unity among
member states just a barren world as
foreign minister and former president of
the European Parliament
be a strong representative and defender
of the European Union's interest and
values in the world Christine Lagarde
will with an international background
and standing as current managing
director of the International Monetary
Fund be a perfect president of the
European Central Bank in addition the
European Council took note of also
Lafond Alliance intentions to nominate
France Timmerman's
and Margaret les target as the higher
ranking vice presidents of the
Commission we also expect Ursula from
the line to ensure an appropriate
geographical balance in the team of vice
president I wish the new leaders all the
best thank you thank you and I'll open
the floor for your questions
Georgie you have to yes hello president
I'm here we got from your active how
about the Parliament I mean I know it's
it's it's not you it's the Parliament
but it was anyway part of the package so
you didn't mention what are the names
that were discussed for the European
Parliament president obviously dividing
the mandate into two you must be aware
that the name of suggest initial for
example is circulating can you elaborate
for these reasons I want to be as
delicate as possible we know that for
the Parliament of the side on the names
our intention is to to have a president
of the Parliament from the Socialists
and Democrats for the first time and
[Music]
candidate from the EPP for the second
time but this is our political opinion
and our political intention but we were
and really it was all of the readers
underlying that this is only for the
Parliament to decide of it thank you yes
thank you Silvia matter firm is the
enemy see looking at the CV the next
president the presidency of ECB is
actually quite a technical role do you
think that given that Madame Lagarde was
a minister for finance in France doesn't
that actually put at risk the
independence of the ECB thank you
I have known Madame Lagarde for many
years and I'm absolutely sure that she
will be a very independent president of
the European Central Bank right good
evening my paper kron4.com Netherlands
actually it's two questions first of all
do you think Spitz Encana doesn't model
now is completely ready to be buried and
secondly do you foresee the possibility
of another package is there a
possibility in the case the European
Parliament says we don't want this
Thanks no I'm not a prophet it's not for
me to assess what is the real chance to
achieve success in the Parliament I will
be there in Strasbourg on Thursday and I
will inform and explain everything I
like I can about this process and our
intentions but of course you're right
it's always question markets this is why
we have Parliament I mean to debate to
discuss to argue and then to decide but
I hope that of course that the political
leaders not only Prime Minister Prime
Minister's will do everything to to
convince our colleagues in the
Parliament to support this project when
it comes to spittin candidate and it was
clear from the very beginning good for
the European Council potemkin Dalton
procedure is not a form of self
obligation it's not a legal obligation
but we wanted to respect candidates
[Music]
leading candidates and I think that the
final result if the demonstration that
that we wanted to respect both people
and this mechanism thank you Jim thank
you very much Jim Burnstein from the
Financial Times the candidates who have
been chosen for their for the lead jobs
they hail from France Germany other
member states in Belgium other member
states in in Western Europe geographical
balance was one of your major aims in
the negotiations how well do you feel
you succeeded our function is that it's
still possible maybe something more
maybe like well lucky that in the
Parliament there's still chance that the
Parliament will vote for a president
from the eastern and central Europe this
is I hope so at least but of course it's
not fast to decide on this and just two
minutes ago I said also that we want to
encourage from the line to to propose an
appropriate geographical balance in the
team of vice-president and you know if
someone asks me what it means I've done
said that Central and Eastern Europe as
well as Italy should be on board in this
process thank you very much this country
mr. Prescott's
thank you